what if anything did rob cowan say to
you about chemistry what's specifically
about the chemistry between amber heard
and jason maloa
just the the fact that they didn't
really have a lot of chemistry together
um you know the the reality is
it's not uncommon on movies for for two
leads to not have chemistry and that
it's sort of movie magic and editorial
the ability to sort of put performances
together and with the magic of you know
a great score and and how you put the
pieces together you can you can
fabricate sort of that chemistry um and
so i think in in at the end of the day i
think if you watch the movie they look
like they had great chemistry but i just
know that through the course of the
post-production that it took a lot of
effort to get there sometimes you don't
sometimes it's very easy you just put
the you know characters on the screen
together and they work and sometimes
it's harder and so
can you give me anything more specific
about what it was with amber heard and
jason momoa that
was difficult for the chemistry
now because it's it's it's it's like
what makes a movie star movie star like
you you you know it when you see it and
the chemistry wasn't there now you've
used the term fabricated a number of
times what did you do to fabricate the
chemistry between amber heard and jason
malmoa
well those are just it's editorial
a good editor and a good filmmaker can
pick the right takes can pick the right
moments
and put scenes together
against score is a big you know the
music in the scene makes a big
difference you can make a happy scene
feel sadder or sad scene feel happier
and so it was sort of the
it's it's
just the magic of post-production
um editing sound sound design music etc
what do you mean by fabricating though i
mean were they literally falsifying or
were they just picking the best
let me just finish my question um were
they picking the best music and picking
the best looks because that's their job
and that's what you do on every
that is what we do in post-production
that's what filmmakers do
no yeah they they they this is
on any production you're doing that
you're you're putting performances
together sometimes it's even easier than
others uh this one
was more difficult
because of the lack of chemistry between
between the two
um but they were able to james wan and
the editor were able to get it to a
place where the end result actually
works and it's great
and in fact that's the job of every
filmmaker right is to put all the
combinations together to make the most
successful production
absolutely
you